do you have aa former Chancellor Helmut
calls most significant political
achievements in his 16 years in office
were German reunification and his role
in establishing the European Union
especially the creation of the EU proved
of paramount importance for the German
economy in recent years and will
continue to do so in the future of the
oven which is presumably all Phil de SU
couldn't even hug inhibitory to in 1996
you became president of the
Confederation of German employers
associations and by then Helmut Kohl had
already been chancellor for 14 years how
did you get to know him you had no
lipton I've seen him in numerous
meetings and negotiations he led them
very rigorously and was very persistent
with his positions but he was also
receptive to counter arguments as long
as they were founded negotiations were
led in a cooperative manner but
obviously with the clear goal of having
his position implemented in the end what
would you say was his biggest economic
accomplishment son the traffic liquor
store 12 his biggest economic
achievement was the European Union which
enabled significant success for the
German economy in the last year cut in
my opinion the European Union that means
the European single market is the
requirement for Germany and for Europe
to be able to compete successfully with
big players internationally Deutschland
that means in order to compete with Asia
and China India Japan the US and South
America we require the European single
market was Oxford America that's a bit
of is Jesus illusion beaten mocked us
for Helmut Kohl the introduction of the
Euro was a means to an end he always
believed in uniting Europe and in deeper
integration
he wanted more unity in Europe beyond
German reunification how would you
assess that today Biba vet and see
destroyed it would be even numbered gold
was driven by the desire to breathe life
into the European Union the creation of
a political European Union as a basis
for our financial and economic Union
would have been the right path you know
but there wasn't enough time for that
Helmut Kohl recognized this and
therefore pursues the path to a possible
financial and economic Union so that a
political union could grow after his
time enough quartzite done Medina
politician
Knox works did he also make mistakes in
economic policy during one chorus the
coal administration started in 1982 in
order to keep the welfare state under
control and to stop and rollback
unemployment which had risen under the
previous Schmidt administration that was
not sufficiently successful especially
the steadily rising expenditures of the
social systems and the associated non
wage labor costs weed in the economy
reduce competitiveness and led to a
situation where unemployment did reach
worrisome levels but the end of the cold
ministration that super filled us even
so in detail in elected he's also
indisputably the Chancellor of German
reunification how much skill did he show
there what would you say about the
economic reunification of the two former
German states quota at MIT why should I
sit down I'd signs coal handle with a
one to one exchange of the East German
market to D marks and the expansion of
the pension scheme to include former
eastern Germany correctly
good offer but that led to economic
problems as well wages in the new
federal states rose dramatically and
competitiveness suffered which led to a
clear tightening of the job market in
hindsight that was certainly the right
thing to do also the decision to set up
the troy hunt to handle remaining GDR
enterprises turned out to be the correct
measure and if we take a trip through
the new federal states we'd conclude
that even if it took a long time it was
the correct approach
what does of CQC and UK for getting so I
said well Susan you worked in the auto
industry for decades you know the day to
day operations which lessons from Helmut
Kohl have stayed with you lecture
wouldn't us eine for house assume fear
Frieden I heart the lesson is that the
European Union is a necessary
requirement for peace freedom prosperity
and social security in our country
especially in the current situation all
efforts have to be undertaken to stop
certain signs of decline in the last
month's and to ensure that the European
Union remains a strong economic and
social political unit in the future
Starkovich awfully here on kuznetsov
sporty teacher einheit 15 plant the
dieter haunt thank you